imagínate que vamos a un casino muy
extraño y en este casino muy extraño va
a haber juegos muy extraños imagínate
que uno de esos juegos llegas y hay una
mesa en la cual solamente hay una bolsa
vacía y enfrente de ti está el encargado
de este juego el cual te va a decir
tengo aquí unas ciertas canicas que voy
a meter a esta bolsa de estas canicas
tres son verdes y dos son rojas y es más
mirad las enseño aquí voy a meter a las
tres canicas verdes y después a mis dos
canicas rojas y bueno el juego va a
consistir en lo siguiente tú sin ver vas
a meter la mano en esta bolsa ojo la
bolsa no es transparente y vas a sacar
dos canicas vas a meter la mano va a
sacar una canica y después vas a meter
la mano y vas a sacar la segunda canica
y bueno si estas canicas son ambas
verdes entonces ya te llevaste el premio
vas a ganar el premio de 1
y un peso si tú logras sacar dos canicas
verdes entonces tú te acercas y le dices
oye suena muy interesante el juego pero
cuánto cuesta el encargado de este juego
te mira fijamente a los ojos y te dice
son 35 centavos 35 centavos para jugar
obviamente si tú ganas entonces lo demás
lo va a cubrir el casino y bueno me
pregunta en esta ocasión va a ser
realmente quieres tú jugar este juego te
conviene jugar este juego y bueno bueno
me refiero al aspecto económico no al
aspecto de diversión en el aspecto
económico te va a interesar jugarlo pues
venga vamos a pensar un poco en las
probabilidades para ver qué tanto me
conviene jugar o no este juego entonces
primero pensemos en cuál es la
probabilidad de que la primera canica
que extraiga saques una canica verde es
más déjeme escribir lo más rápido que la
primera sea verde la primera sea verde
muy bien pues primero habrá que checar
cuáles son los posibles resultados que
podemos obtener y cómo las cinco canicas
son exactamente iguales es decir no hay
ninguna que se sienta distinta a otra y
ojo de estas cinco canicas solamente
tres satish
que son verdes por lo tanto la
probabilidad de obtener la primera verde
va a ser 3 sobre 5 por lo tanto tienes
una probabilidad de tres quintos de
seguir en el juego pero no queremos la
probabilidad de que sigas en el juego yo
lo que quiero es la probabilidad de que
te mantengas en el juego y lo ganes por
lo tanto lo que queremos es que la
primera sea verde y además que la
segunda sea verde estos escritos
matemáticas lo vamos a poner como la
probabilidad de que la primera sea verde
lo voy a poner con p de verde y además y
además intersección que la segunda
también sea verde y bueno tal vez te
atrevas a decir oye es que la
probabilidad de que la segunda sea verde
es exactamente la misma que la
probabilidad de que la primera sea verde
y bueno ya con esto obtendríamos tres
quintos por tres quintos y ese es mi
resultado pero qué crees hay que tener
cuidado porque aquí viene algo muy
importante tú lo que vas a hacer es
sacar la primera canica verde y no la
vas a regresar de nuevo a la bolsa lo
que vas a hacer es sacar la primera
canica verde y ponerla a un lado
y después volver a meter la mano en la
bolsa y sacar la segunda canica por lo
tanto la segunda vez que tú metes la
mano en la bolsa va a cambiar la
probabilidad porque ya no son las mismas
canicas y justo a esto se le llama que
los eventos no sean independientes o
dicho de otra manera que sean eventos
dependientes o en este caso en
particular la segunda vez que tú metas
la mano en la bolsa va a depender de la
primera canica que sacaste la segunda
vez depende de la primera vez que
metiste la mano en la bolsa si la
primera canica que sacaste es verde
entonces la segunda vez que metas la
mano ya no vas a tener la probabilidad
de tres canicas verdes sobre cinco
canicas que tenías por lo tanto esta
probabilidad que buscamos en efecto es
la probabilidad de que la primera sea
verde la probabilidad de que la primera
sea verde que multiplica a la
probabilidad de que la segunda sea verde
esta línea va a significar dado un dado
que la primera fue verde si es una
multiplicación de probabilidades pero la
segunda probabilidad es una probabilidad
condicional ahora cuál es la
probabilidad de que la segunda sea verde
dado que la primera fue verde ahora cuál
es la probabilidad de que la segunda
canica sea verde dado que la primera fue
verde pues ya tenemos este dibujo aquí
ahora tenemos cuatro canicas cuatro
posibles resultados 15 esta vez 4 y
solamente dos de ellos cumplen que son
verde solamente dos de estas canicas
cumplen que son verdes por lo tanto la
probabilidad de que tu primer canicas
sea verde intersección que tu segunda
canica sea verde es la probabilidad de
que tu primer canica sea verde lo cual
era tres quintos que va a multiplicar a
la probabilidad de que la segunda sea
verde dado que la primera es verde es
decir dos cuartos la segunda vez tenemos
cuatro canicas y de estas cuatro canicas
solamente dos son verdes y bueno cuál es
esta probabilidad total tres quintos por
dos cuartos bueno dos cuartos es lo
mismo que un medio por lo tanto esto es
lo mismo que tres quintos por un medio
lo cual es tres décimos o esto lo
podemos escribir como 0.30 o en su dado
caso como
un 30 por ciento de probabilidad el 30
por ciento de probabilidad de obtener
dos canicas verdes sacando una primero y
la segunda después sin tener reemplazo y
bueno ya que tenemos de probabilidad
déjame te hago otra vez la pregunta
jugarías este juego pues solamente
tienes una probabilidad del 30 por
ciento de ganar este peso es decir que
si tú juegas este juego muchas muchas
muchas muchas muchas veces de todas
maneras cada vez que tú juegues este
juego vas a tener solamente una
probabilidad de ganar del 30 por ciento
ya está lo podemos calcular
matemáticamente 30 por ciento de obtener
un peso es lo mismo que 30 centavos es
decir si tú juegas varias varias varias
veces este juego al final vas a obtener
que siempre vas a tener una probabilidad
del 30 por ciento ahora tú vas a querer
dar 35 centavos a alguien para tú
solamente tener una probabilidad de
ganar del 30 por ciento es decir 30
centavos
no vas a querer jugar este juego y bueno
al final solamente te quiero dejar con
esta pregunta jugarías este juego si lo
que puedes hacer es regresar otra vez la
canica verde es decir si puedes
reemplazar la canica verde de nuevo
piénsalo y escríbeme un comentario